previously on stardom I started a
company called not vine which is a
platform to share 6.1 second looping
videos I have a rich nemesis called REO
who embarrassed me in a game of chess I
started to work on not fine and then
suddenly Aria launched refined before us
allowing people to share 5.9 second
videos
he beat me to it man he launched revine
before not buying what a sly
[ __ ] man he knew exactly what I
was doing and he just cut me off just
like that and now I'm not the first
anymore
it's crazy like you know I don't know
why he has to do that I mean doesn't he
have already enough money it's just
crazy about like every time I feel like
I hit a brick wall and then I get so
close to what I want and then boom
another brick wall it's frustrating
sometimes just feels like a like a
stupid game like someone's looking over
my shoulders just like making a fool out
of myself
it's making me running around like an
idiot
I know he's you hungry man I kind of
forgot you were here
nah I'm good
cool
do you ever feel like
we're part of a shell or something like
all the obstacles we come up against
it's so hard they seem like they're
impossible but the very last second we
always solve it or something it's like
The Truman Show with Jim Carrey give it
feel that way nope not at all no you're
talking about
not even like a little bit you mean like
imagine if this whole thing this whole
situation that we're in is all just for
our webseries for like a YouTube channel
or something is that we're saying yeah
come on man that's so silly and you have
way too much imagination I mean if we
were a webseries it would be a pretty
damn boring webseries or thing
so which is why I can yuan is definitely
the best school to go to read wait I
like get here we're just outside and
then we walked here yeah but what was
the path that we came from the path dude
we just took the road yeah okay whatever
sandwiches oh yeah sure
thank you thanks alright so let me tell
you why every vine is a huge threat or
success it all comes down to marketing
basically the perception of our brands
now nobody knows about Ron Fineman but
everyone knows about rewind suddenly he
became the first member and in marketing
that is extremely important especially
for a product like not fine or refined
perception to be the best is actually
way more important to actually be the
best I mean let's say our servers can
handle you know way more requests and
our UI is slightly better does that make
us the best no not really because in
people's minds revine was the first
looping video company hence the best
company and since they've launched
before us they can brand themselves as
whatever they want because the public
will believe them now let's take an
example
I think ketchup what company do you
think makes a nice ketchup all right
exactly Heinz but that's because there
were first movers that's what you think
they're the best now if you think about
it who do you think the second company
is for ketchups exactly you don't know
nobody cares nobody cares when you're
second everyone only cares when you're
first
so same thing for Jack Daniels for
whiskey and like Tesla for electric cars
that's why we need to be the first for
diluting videos but we're not so
basically now people think of looping
videos they'll think of refined not not
line that's because they are the market
leader and no matter what we can't be
first anymore however not always lost
though we cannot be first in the looping
video sharing platform we can try to be
first on something else basically we
have to avoid the competition and come
up with our own product category
here's an example IBM used to be the
leading company for computers right but
then other companies want to get in on
the action like have you heard of burrow
control data and CR or Sperry I mean the
shoe company no did I'm talking about
computers right now why would I talk
about shoes anyways those were companies
that want to make computers also the
only one who succeeded and often called
the second largest computer company was
Dec why were they successful because
they weren't competing in the computer
market they were competing in the micro
computers so they were the first
microcomputer product category what
happened to the other companies those
other companies were too focused on
getting people to like their brand which
is extremely hard by the way because
once a perception is made by person it's
really hard to change their minds what
they should have done is to try to think
of a subcategory than diggeth rhymin and
be first at people don't give a [ __ ]
what's better they care about what's new
so here's my proposal a new category we
are going to make for our non looping
videos on our platforms for ours genius
that was a joke
but yeah I don't I just haven't thought
about anything yet but I mean we have to
pivot that TechCrunch article really did
a number on us hold if he sees every
engineer they all know about rebut
everyone the valley knows about
everybody
yeah I mean we basically lost her first
mover advantage wait everyone in the
valley knows about it wait it wasn't
only tech rush on the loop on it yeah
only TechCrunch wrote about it dude
nobody in the valley makes videos only
tech nerds know about repining revine is
first in the minds of engineers but
they're in our target market so we're
not too late to be diverse in the minds
of creators and social influencers
[Music]
you know always want to go myself
once we're for like I own a boat if you
keep a dock here in the whole time it's
like you're trapped here forever kind of
like us right
wait what do you mean
I didn't say
you know if you want to try owning a
boat I got this great game od say God
tried it's really realistic you say it's
really realistic
it's really realistic it's like The
Truman Show what was the path sandwiches
kind of like us right
hey Dom can I talk to you for a sec yeah
what's up so I ran the simulation you
asked me to and not find one yeah
they're not fine one we've got the
preliminary results of the experiment
and it looks like the success rate is
only about 17% should be terminated no
let's keep it running there's always a
chance the metrics will increase how are
the other simulations going well some of
the others seem promising like vine Lee
in the vine book I continue to report
and highlight the features that are most
predictive of our success that'll be
great but let's keep an eye on that not
final I'm really curious how it ends it
might just tell us the perfect launch
strategy
[Music]
April Fool's everybody so yeah we are
not in the simulation this episode is
not part of the canon so don't worry
about that so I just want to say thank
you for watching this episode hope you
liked it if you liked it don't forget to
subscribe and then also like this video
thank you so much just a little
announcement I am going to take a break
on the startup it series I'm going to
skip episode 6 so instead of doing it
next month I'm gonna do it next next
month sorry about that but I need take a
break and the reason why I'm taking a
break is actually because I want to make
more videos and these videos take a long
time and I kind of want to try to make
two videos a week for the next month a
lot of exciting stuff that I'm gonna do
so hopefully you're gonna enjoy the
content now put out later but yeah so
for startup series you're gonna have to
wait a little bit for that thanks